[Music]
can you please
describe what happened in molly about
the boxer part that was a fantastic part
i'm not going to want to get you to give
away anything else but like one story
sure so i go over to my time i'm a
writer and a boxer
now i'd come off this film rain of fire
so i wasn't actually i was
in pretty good actual physical shape and
i had a big beard
and uh bald head and you know someone
was like i
had a picture from the set with me with
a bloody nose
and it was stunt blood and i'd show them
that i was like i'm 42 wins and two
losses and
this picture here i won this one and
they'd be like wow
well they love to wrestle in africa and
they love to wrestle in mali
so in these walkabouts from village to
village
a strong white man named dauda me
um is coming to village he
he beat me boxer box them in so i'd show
up in the young bucks of the of the of
the villages would come up and they'd
kind of
little push and you know kind of and i
was in a few circumstances early that i
was like i
really would rather not get into a match
with these guys
and i remember i would like hop into a
chuck norris
pose or something eastern right and they
would go whoa
chuck norris chuck oh chuck norris so
they would always back up because it
seemed so an
alien to them right um but this one
day we had hiked 15 miles to this
village benjimoto and i'm doing what i
did
most days when i arrived to the village
laying on my back on the ground
shirtless taking my shoes and socks off
stretching out from a long day and
each one show up in the village that's
when the community and all the villagers
gather around
each village i would go to i was going
to be the knights entertainment i looked
different i was a traveler i was a
new person in their village anyway on
this particular night there's about 25
30 villagers around and
these two young men about eighteen to
twenty step forward and start i could do
the back
everything and i could just tell they
were talking
at me even though i didn't know what
they said i could tell they had a
challenging tone and i look over my
buddy issa it was my guy and i said
are they talking [ __ ] he did yes he says
they say they are the champion uh
wrestlers of audi village and they want
to challenge
strong white to my name down to two
wrestling match well my heartbeat starts
going up a little bit and i continue
stretch and i'm laying there thinking
what i'm gonna do
and all of a sudden the pitch of the the
villagers around me just
hits the roof and i look up and these
two young guys
just bolt well why do they bolt
well because who stepped up in their
place was michelle
five foot nine tree trunk legs burlap
bag with rope wrapped around it
this is the real champion of the village
and he didn't like
the two young bucks were saying they
were champions well without saying a
word he comes and stands over me points
to me on the ground points to his heart
and then points over to the right
my heartbeat starts going up i know this
is a direct challenge for me to
to to wrestle as i'm sitting there going
oh geez don't do this this is crazy
i'm already starting to get up because
the voice in the other ear saying like
you will regret this if you don't do
this you have to
so i stand up in front of him point to
his chest point to my chest
and then turn and head towards where he
pointed
which was to a big dirt pit
here we go villagers are happy now we've
got great entertainment right
i'm going i don't know the rules of this
you can
bite break arms god hit i don't know but
i'm going with it i'm going with it
so we get in the ring now all the
villages around there's about 80
villagers around
and we stand up in front of each other
i'm trying to figure out the rules and
he looks at me steps forward and
puts a solid hand on my right hip and
looks at me to mirror him i do the same
to his head
then he does the other hand he has me by
the by by the hip with two two hands
i have him by the hip with two hands
then he lowers his forehead
and just rubs it down on my clavicle
here
nooses his forehead down into it so i do
the same now we're ear to ear
we have each other's hips and we're like
two bulls in the middle of this
dirt pit right and the chief comes
around
puts a hand on both their heads and i
hear him go which i
take to mean ding ding and i was correct
so here we go i'm swiping for his legs
they're huge
uh um i i i get him out of her i get him
on his side he flips me over one time he
comes at me again and i get him in the
headlock he somersaults over me anyway
it goes round and round for what felt
like six minutes was probably
like two minutes also the chief steps in
and separates us
the crowd is going crazy i'm
hyperventilating i'm sweating i'd had
these talismans that were sown in my
beard they've been ripped out i got
blood all down my chin
down my chest my knees are bleeding my
ankles are bleeding i'm soaking sweat
and all of a sudden the chief goes
this means round two i guess i look at
michelle
who's just standing there barely
breathing hard with a glisten of sweat
on him and he's just straight facing me
going
not happy with how that last round went
which i did pretty good in and i think
this is why i wasn't happy
so here we go hand to hip hand to hip
head down here we go dot we're off again
man here we go again
i mean flip each other pin each other
sands flying blood's flying spits flying
we go over never never get the other
completely pinned down we do this for
another what felt like 15
minutes but now the chief steps in
breaks us up
grabs both our hands raises them to the
sky and the villagers go
crazy well right after he lets go of our
hands michelle
runs off just like those two men those
two young boys earlier just
darted sprinted off i don't know where
he went
and all the villagers come in and
encapsulate me and start going
down that and they're banging me on the
back i'm like down
down and i'm going okay well this is
great
we go through that that night i'm
feeling very good about myself i feel
like i'd handled you know
like i did all right in the wrestling
match and and i i get on the roof
sleeping on the hut that night
and i'm feeling very good about my day
wow what an
adventure what i'm so glad i took the
challenge i did that
and and i'm laying there and and
the southern cross revealed itself to me
for the very first time in my life
crystal clear in the sky i laid there
for an hour and a half saw 29 shooting
stars
all of these celestial suggestions going
da
da i'm sitting there feeling like oh yes
it's me i'm in the cradle of god i've
crossed the truth i'm the chosen one
this is
super wow preserve this moment matthew
well i'm starting to doze off that doze
off one of my nostrils kind of full of
snot so i kind of
hock up a loogie and i'd lean up and i
go
to spit it off the roof that i was on
into the field
well the lugia never made it to the
field actually the look he made it about
eight inches from my face
and then boomeranged back across my face
like a wet oyster
i had forgot i had a mosquito net tied
around my head
[Laughter]
tied around my head and i remember
starting to cackle laugh
just like that because i was like oh
just when you thought
you had the direct line to
the divine you spit a loogie in your
face
touched well anyway i slept great that
night i got up the next morning
and as we left the village guess who was
waiting at the edge of the village
michelle man i had wrestled the night
before
without saying a word he reached out
took my hand
it was 15 miles to the next village he
walked with me held my hand for the
entire 15 miles to the next village
without saying a word as soon as i got
to the boundary of that next village
he let go of my hand bowed and turned
around and walked home
that night i'm sitting there with isa
and my guy and i said he said i got to
talk about last night the wrestling
match at me i think i did
i think i did pretty well i mean he goes
[Music]
do very very well this man michelle
he's not only champion of this village
he's champion of this village and tree
village back
oh everybody in village think that
michelle going to have strong white men
down
on his back in 10 seconds no you handled
michelle that was the word i remember
very clearly you handled
michelle i wasn't going to talk about
win or lose was you handled
and then he said something really funny
he goes yes
you come back we make money
[Laughter]
intermedia intermediate intermediate
wrestling matches right
so i did go back
five and a half years later
showed up on issa's doorsteps in mopty
and told him
i want to do the same trip we did back
in 99 and we got a boat went up found
ali did the the dot went to village
talked to the village
we got to benjamita where i had the
wrestling match there's michelle
michelle had had five kids
since then he had a broken hip so there
was no wrestling match
but we had a great night went to bed
next morning i woke up to walk to the
next village 15 miles away
and guess who was waiting at the
boundary of the village with an open
hand
which he grabbed mine and walked me the
15 miles to the next village without
saying a word
when we got to that boundary bowed
turned around and walked back
[Music]
michelle